good morning believe nation today's
message is push through over to you
lin-manuel Miranda I know it's as you
say ciose to right Hamilton but I know
we might as teenagers thank you for
riding I said right and we have trouble
that oh my god did you want to give up
did you ever feel like that all the time
all the time and then you push through
it like you push through it because
what's the alternative you're gonna
leave that idea stuck in your head
forever
that sucks the alternative is you go
through life and you had this great idea
and nothing came of it because you've
got tired and yeah sometimes you don't
go to the party that all your friends
are at because the idea is calling to
you in that moment wait for it's a great
example of that I was on my way to my
friend's birthday party when that lyric
showed up when death doesn't
discriminate showed up in my head idea
came on the a down I started writing it
down in the train and I can eat that of
the a train break dancers are dancing I
have my headphones on I get out I the
whole chorus comes all at once I write
it down and I suddenly see the shape of
the whole song I was just like the
chorus is burr that's who he is I go
into my friend's party I go hey what's
that man happy birthday
I gotta go I get on the L train and I
write the rest of the song on the way
back home from the L to the a backup to
207 Street you have to do that sometimes
you have to say no to your friends to
say yes to your work because what are
you gonna do like lose that idea because
you decided like have a drink with your
friends like it's not worth it
your friend will be there so what do you
think I think about all those times that
I got really tired
and I did not want to go to that dance
rehearsal I felt like I want to go have
dinner with my friends and
teach my class you know all those times
that I thought about that's like well I
had to kind of bring it all down and
keep focused on why I'm doing the things
I'm doing the reason why I teach my
classes because I want to make a
difference in someone's life
I get a lot of passion from teaching
from seeing my students connect with
each other being friends them having
compassion for each other
and really really connecting in that way
anytime I'm super tired and I'm sick I
will think about why am I even doing
this and if it's bigger than having that
drink with your friend or going out for
dinner or watching that Netflix movie
then you have to push through you have
to push through because the goal is a
lot bigger than that particular moment
and honestly the tiredness the
sleepiness it all passes once you know
what you're focused on I like it I think
one of the little things about
entrepreneurship that people don't talk
enough about is that everybody thinks
about quitting at some point it's not
something that we go out and share
because you don't want to be seen as a
failure or be seen as negative but
everybody at some point thinks about
putting because it's hard what you're
doing is hard if it's important then
it's then it's gonna be hard you're
doing things that haven't been done
before and so you're not cheating at
some point get exhausted and think about
giving up and the thing that keeps you
going is the love for what you're doing
and so many businesses fail because the
founder doesn't really love the business
up there in I want to start a YouTube
channel because I want to be some big
celebrity on YouTube but I don't
actually like making videos it's not
gonna happen right I want to be a dance
instructor it's only gonna happen if you
love dancing like you you will not put
in the work and do all the rehearsals
and the practice and watch the videos
and take the private lessons and go to
the congress's and do all the work that
you need to do to become a great dancer
if all you care about is you know being
up on stage and teaching the class you
have to love the process and I still
come back to Jerry Seinfeld had this
great quote talking about doing the work
that others see is torture if I look at
Lily's schedule I might say that's crazy
you know I couldn't do that or people
my youtube schedule say that's crazy I
couldn't do that the work that other
people see is torture you enjoy the
torture you enjoy the work not every
single day but you enjoy the process if
you don't enjoy the process you're gonna
quit there's abundance of the analysis
so it has to be something that you love
so much that you'll push through
anything to go out and accomplish so the
question of the day today is what are
the challenges you're facing right now
that you need to push through mmm
leaving the comments below we're gonna
join in the discussion so thank you guys
so much for watching I hope you have an
amazing day we believe in you and hope
you continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is and we'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso